if you smack two heavy metal balls
together the energy of their Collision
will be focused at such a small Point
enough heat can be produced to literally
burn a hole through paper try this at
home it smells like smoke but let's make
it even hotter first I'll need to rust
up one of these balls a bowl of water
should do the trick ten days later
that's a rusty meatball we'll wrap the
other ball in aluminum foil turn down
the lights put on some ear and eye
protection and start whacking until this
happens did you see that that is molten
slag at more than 4 500 degrees
Fahrenheit now that didn't happen
because I'm so strong even though I am
it happened because the colliding balls
produced the ignition temperature needed
for a thermite reaction the aluminum
reduced the iron oxide the rust on the
ball to form aluminum oxide Elemental
iron and much more heat than I put in
now that's what I call exothermic redox